how do you identify what's next you know
I just read a lot right I'm just one of
those guys that just consumes
information mostly Tech but it could be
anything Steve Jobs had this this one
quote that really stuck with me he said
everything's a remix and if you look at
the early days of the Apple products
there was this company back in the day
called Xerox Park and Xerox came out
with the first Mouse driven PC but their
marketing sucked and they had no idea
what they were doing no one knew what
they're about Steve Jobs gave me a
little bit of this a little bit remixed
and Bam right all of a sudden you got
apple and then a Macintosh and for me
the more you learn the more you know how
to remix and that's what this is all
about so how do you go from YouTube
which was the first platform for video
that got big to Instagram to Snapchat
and know okay do I want to be on
Discover do I want to be on reels do I
want to be on Tick Tock and if I do this
how's YouTube going to treat me and all
the decisions you guys have got to make
on a daily basis need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn from one of the best
Mark Cuban and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
and the fact that like we're just
talking you created all these products
and you wanted to be organic that's a
business decision too and then you have
to learn by trial and error right you
were curious about what might work you
know obviously you know you're walking
proof of what does work right and now
you've got to be able to continue to
make those decisions because in this
business with all the margins on these
projects everybody's coming at you all
the time right yeah and they think they
can do the exact same thing but it's not
that easy but for me it's like that's
why I try to stay ahead because whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's VR whether it's crypto whether it's
metaverse all these things may not be
prime time yet but I want to know when
they will be and I want to be out front
when they when they are rule number two
is know how to sell you gotta sell yeah
because the in my experiences the the
CEOs the owners the founders that didn't
sell they all failed yeah with no
exceptions a hundred percent of them
failed and you know when you're just
starting and it's just you who else is
going to sell nobody okay
and that's the other you know and that
leads to another mistake entrepreneurs
make they they try to hit hiring home
runs right so when the minute they hit a
roadblock I'll just hire a you know I'll
hire a new marketing person right or
I'll hire a new head of sales
um hope thinking that oh this person's
amazing no one's ever hired somebody and
said they suck really bad of course
right oh I found the most amazing person
why did they leave the last five jobs oh
they were amazing but right
um that's such a good point see that's
what I love how your brain works it's
like exactly it's so true it's so
practical and common sense it's
pragmatic yeah right common sense but
Common Sense isn't so common no I know
you know you just ask why why'd they
leave you know but but entrepreneurs
tend to think okay I'm hiring this
amazing marketing person and he or she
is is going to know what to do yeah and
then they tell that to their investors
because that's typically why they're
hiring a marketing person and they say
oh this person's amazing you know our
next quarter is going to be great then
it's not then they go to the next
marketing person you know then they're
in this hamster wheel again and they're
screwed and so we're relying on other
people well yes and that's the whole
thing right you you've got to be able to
solve the problems yourself self-reliant
you know you know at some point your
business gets bigger and you have to
learn how to do a lot of other things
you know when you go to five people it's
one thing you go to 10 or 15 it's
another challenge you know as you learn
how to manage and deal with people but
at the same time if you're not great at
your core competency how are you going
to train those people right how are you
going to know what the the goals are for
the organization how to communicate to
them how to do what you need them to do
rule number three is learn about crypto
thinking about the next big opportunity
in the cryptocurrency space into your
credit you were around for D5 summer D5
was a big opportunity in 2020 you were
early in saying ethereum and nfts is you
know possibly going to be really big and
it was really big after cryptocurrency
finds the bottom do you have any
thoughts about the next big opportunity
in the space it just comes down to
Applications if you guys got great ideas
I'm wide open right I'm tired of the
pitches I'm getting like new D5
for new you know there's a great analogy
between what happened in Silicon Valley
um with SAS software and other
applications even like uber right where
tons of money came in and subsidized all
these apps Uber is just now starting to
make money 15 years or whatever it is 12
years later you know there's other apps
that same thing and so what happened
with apps like I was an investor in box
and I actually wanted them to just
generate Revenue as opposed to raise
money to subsidize free
um online storage and so um
they went their way they bought me out
and it took them I don't even know how
many years for them to make money
um I'm never a big fan of raising
hundreds of millions of dollars to do
tens of millions in business but that's
exactly what happened in crypto and but
crypto was distorted because people
looked at the token valuations and so
what would happen is they go out and do
a token sale and generate a bunch of
capital or even worse they'd raise
hundreds of millions of dollars from um
VCS and use that money to create a fake
yield right you so we saw that with
anchor right where it was like okay
we're offering you 20 percent
and then they hope that they'd be able
to generate enough loans to cover the 20
percent
never came close
all that yield was subsidized all those
five seven eight ten twenty fifty ninety
100 yields
um have always been subsidized by
investors now with those investors not
willing to subsidize anymore you're not
seeing the crazy yields and you're not
even seeing the inflationary yields
um from the blockchains anymore you know
where you would say okay you know
um if you stake this we're gonna pay you
four percent or eight percent or twelve
percent and they can't even afford to do
that because you know if you inflate too
much there's not enough intrinsic demand
to cover that inflation and your token
price is going to drop and that makes
your investors mad that makes your
speculators mad
and it ignores the fact that to be a
real business you have to be a real
business and crypto doesn't change any
of that rule number four is seize
opportunities covid you have said has
changed the world in terms of
opportunities uh it's obviously hurt
people but it's obviously help people
who are entrepreneurial so you've said
this is a good time to actually figure
out new businesses new areas of business
is that fair statement yeah you know
it's so unfortunate but it's true I mean
you know we've heard Warren Buffett say
you know buy when there's blood in the
streets and it's almost analogous here
so many small businesses are closing so
many you know retail stores are closing
malls are are you know going bankrupt
um companies that are unable to
transition to to selling digitally or or
really taking full advantage of
e-commerce or struggling big companies
don't understand don't really aren't
sure about how to protect our Legacy
businesses that type of uncertainty
creates a lot of opportunity unity and
combine that with people becoming far
more comfortable with purchasing online
and and living a digital lifestyle I
think there's a lot of unique
opportunities that are available to
people who who are creative who have a
vision for the future I think you know
10 15 20 years we'll look back and
they'll be 10 20 30 world-class
companies that were created by people
who we probably are thinking are crazy
right about now
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is utilize your
resources I have a question for you do
you think that like people like because
I also know that you kind of came from
from nothing just know your family yeah
you weren't handed anything no nothing
do you think it's harder for people now
to reach the level of success that you
have because
um because of a saturation no no I think
it's easier you think it's easier now I
think it's easier I mean let's look at
you all right you all a good idea good
connection to people right just went for
it and when other people might say you
do a b and c or you should do a b and c
you did d e and f right and found your
angle and you know the only thing that
can stop you is would it work or you
know was it a good idea or not and
that's the thing like you have so many
tools like back in the day you know you
had to buy these big computers and you
know it was more expensive now you get a
laptop or an iPad and you get an
internet connection and you can have any
Tech a couple of years right now I think
social media too and I mean look what
we're doing now right we're doing this
and you're gonna have it up on YouTube
and streaming it and millions of people
are going to be able to get to it yeah
and it's not like you're spending
millions of dollars like a TV show or a
movie would have been 25 years ago right
it's actually easier now on one hand the
tools are are cheaper and more
accessible the other hand there's more
competition rule number six is learn to
manage your time how do you do all of
this I mean honestly like your schedule
between the Shark Tank Shark Tank all
those companies do doing like these
things I mean like what time are you
waking up in the morning 6 5 36 like
what's the date like give me a day in
your life you probably should admit this
but like I'll get up at 5 36
particularly during the school year my
kids are going to school you have three
kids yeah 12 15 and 18. yeah are you
involved do you see these kids because
how are you able to do all I don't
travel that much and unless they're out
doing stuff really right now my middle
daughter
um Melissa is at Camp my wife and my
youngest son Jake who's 12 are in
Iceland right now they went on a trip
because while I'm shooting Shark Tank
that's when they all know to go do their
trips that's a good idea yeah and then
my oldest is on a trip as well so with
her class and so all you know so while
we're shooting they're gone and so
that's when I pack everything in and
then you do everything yeah but
otherwise you know I can do one day
trips here or one day trips there
because you know I'd rather spend time
with my family so you so you are like
you spend a lot of time with your yeah
of course yeah that's the best yeah
that's the best part of my life okay so
tell me the day give me your daily you
wake up at you said six o'clock wake up
yeah 5 36 do you know say all right
everybody gets everybody going to school
if that's what's up and um then do my
email and typically get back in bed do
my email get through any emergencies go
back take a nap rule number seven is
never be afraid to try what's the worst
idea you've ever read so like right out
of school I got fired from a job and
then um I was trying to come up with
something to sell and it was powdered
milk and it was just I'm like well
people need to save money on milk so you
know if it doesn't taste quite as good
no I learned the hard way that didn't
last a week
um what other have I up
I mean it's just you know I'm like
everybody else still right it's just
like you'll think of something yeah and
you'll start thinking about it and then
you'll Google it right and you'll see if
it's out there
it's not no one's done this before then
you'll tell your guys or your friends
like okay that's not bad getting a
little traction that way a little
traction confidence but then you got to
try to actually get someone to buy it
right and that's always the hard part
and what people forget you know when you
go out there and start googling and it's
not there there's a pretty good chance
it's because they went out of business
right and it's already been there but um
yeah I've I've had plenty plenty of bad
ideas
um but that's okay man you know like I
tell everybody you only gotta be right
once yeah does no one no one remembers
like how many times I screwed up you
know just gotta be right once rule
number eight is spend time with family
what do you do on your free time like
when you can do anything yeah now it's
my kids right my kids are 12 15 and 18.
so I'm at that spot now we're like going
to play one-on-one with my son is pretty
cool just you know my 18 year old
daughter is getting ready to go to
college so just getting any of our time
is cool
um and then my middle daughter is you
know is is just unique man she's just
she's crazy and I love hanging time so
that that's really like my number one
priority now if it wasn't family and if
it was not business what do you enjoy
you play golf I'm not a golfer I hate
golf but I play I play pickup basketball
so like a couple times a week I'll go
play pick up basketball go work out
um you know go hang with my friends
whatever chill but yeah but now you know
it's family and and business and and
working out more than anything else rule
number nine is grow organically would
you say the number one not to Pivot that
but like what you said the number one
reason why people are failing then is
because their lack of ability to work
hard and to kind of dig in what would it
be no I I'd say they're misguided and
they sell themselves they lie to
themselves when they start right oh I
think this business is good everybody
goes through that same process with the
new business you know hey what do you
think about this idea right then you go
on Google and you look up oh I don't see
it it's great of course no one tells you
that it's not there because 50 companies
have failed doing the same thing and
there's nothing nothing left to show
that they died but you know then you get
excited you check with your friends and
then they try to raise money yeah that's
what screws them up right raising money
is not an accomplishment it's an
obligation yeah you know if at all
possible you want to start just
organically with Sweat Equity those are
the best businesses because you get to
you get to retain 100 of it right you
know and there's no rush and then the
second mistake people make is they push
the Top Line instead of the bottom line
or gross margin dollars yeah you know
it's like Oh I'm a million in sales like
that's an accomplishment or 10 million
where like if you've raised funding you
have your quote-unquote kpis right yeah
right or what is what's new on qoks or
something there's something ridiculous
that um qkp I don't know they always
come up with these actors what is it I
don't know yeah just when I started
seeing
and so everybody's like oh yeah you know
and they think it's an accomplishment if
you're doing I went from one million to
5 million in sales
okay that's somewhat great but what
matters is what's your gross margin
right because if you're in that hamster
wheel where you're growing but you need
to keep on raising money to grow right
no you see what's happening now when
people can't raise money you're done you
know and While others have said well you
know I've you know raised 30 million or
50 or 100 million dollars unless you
have a really good reason you know that
your relativity space and you need to
raise money because you're building you
know 80 foot tall 3D printers yeah right
you're not going to do that out of your
basement but for most entrepreneurs it's
something where there it's an Arbitrage
on their time yeah right here's I can do
this more efficiently than Jan or Mark
can so it's worth it for General Mark to
buy this product or service from me so
that they can use their time more
efficiently and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is invest wisely how do you know like is
it a gut feeling when you like when
you're investing in somebody to say I
think they can do it or like yeah I mean
I can tell I've been done I've done this
so many times that
um different people have different
qualities you know the fight they've
been through but you know and really
it's not just the fight but it's how
little they talk about the fight you
know I have a rule that the longer the
back story the worse the investment so
there there's a lot of people been
through a lot of challenges and a lot of
difficulties and they want to tell you
about it right and that's all they want
to talk about whereas with Arlen you
know I got a glimpse of our backstory
but she started talking about the
company she's investing and why and you
know she knew what she was doing and
more importantly she was able to give me
access to entrepreneurs that I couldn't
get access to on my own and that really
was the Clincher
I'm not a big Mentor guy I've always
been a believer that if you really want
to learn something and be great at
something you have to put in the time a
lot of people look for mentors as
shortcuts when in reality maybe they
help you a little bit maybe they help
you avoid some mistakes but when you're
just getting started out in particular
it's okay to make those mistakes and
more importantly you have to make the
commitment to put in the time to learn
what you need to learn to be great at
something or good at what you want to be
good at you almost have to have that
drive like in other words you can't fake
it you can't like pretend that you want
to read about Ted Turner and okay I'll
Skip One movie
your soul yeah I mean you can fake it
too make it in a lot of areas
particularly if you're working for
somebody else but at the end of the day
um if you're going to be great at
something you've got to make the effort
to be great at something whether it's
Sports whether it's physics math science
business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to to learn and
particularly if you're in the technology
industry because it changes every day
you know when I got started and and you
know after I got I got it I was a
bartender when I first came to Dallas
got into the PC industry got fired
started my own company but there I
learned early on that there was always
something new and most people didn't put
in the time to learn it it's like now
with artificial intelligence lots of
people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something I've always
enjoyed so that I've been fortunate
we're just about to graduate from
college right what's the advice
um you don't need the perfect job you
know
um part of the problem is you probably
have a hundred thousand dollars of debt
right
um and you got to pay off for all that
um
and that's really up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um my advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just enormous it's
you paid all that money to learn now
here's your chance to get paid to learn
and you don't need the perfect job you
need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge added to
your foundation because
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22. hell no there's just no chance
that the 30 year old or even the 25 year
old is going to look back at the 21 or
22 year old you and say oh that dude had
it all together knew exactly what was up
right he's going to look back and go
beer pong what were you thinking you
know and so it don't expect to have all
the answers and don't try to get the
perfect job go out there and get paid to
have different experiences and it's okay
to jump from job to job if it's not the
right job you are getting paid to learn
flip it and then use that to build your
knowledge and learn more about yourself
learn how to learn in business and see
where it can take you how people
perceive entrepreneurs is changing
dramatically and how entrepreneurs are
contributing to society is changing
right now as we speak and I see it on
Shark Tank right companies coming on
Shark Tank now particularly from younger
entrepreneurs have a social component
but you don't want to buy something
unless you think the company is
contributing and even more so now a lot
of people are saying you know what if
you're an entrepreneur and you happen to
get rich that's bad right and so
entrepreneurs people particularly my
generation have kind of segregated
themselves into okay just get me all the
money I can into okay there's can't be
such a thing as compassionate capitalism
and really it's falling on you guys now
to set the message if you're going to
are going to be an entrepreneur
having a social component is good being
a compassionate entrepreneur is better
because when you can change things when
you can hire people like I had to go
back through the companies that I
control now and I said I wanted to make
sure that nobody who works for in
particular the arena and the Mavs is on
public assistance
because it's wrong I think it's wrong
that somebody who works for me doesn't
make enough money to be on public
assistance that's the type of attitude I
think that needs to change now with
entrepreneurs and that's now becoming
part of your responsibility and I think
that's critically important you know
guys like me women like me can look and
backtrack and backfill and where we've
made mistakes and I've made plenty and
I've learned from them
but it's your opportunity and I think
it's critically important to recognize
that you are going to set the tone for
how people perceive entrepreneurs going
forward and if you introduce compassion
and you look at the needs of the people
that work from you right from the
beginning I think you're going to have
stronger companies less turnover and
better results you may not be a leader
to anybody more than you know the two
people who work for you but it's still a
responsibility and I think
um as you gain more success however you
define that
being a leader becomes more and more
important how you define success becomes
more and more important what you're able
to do and the impact you're able to have
becomes more and more important where I
am in my life at this point
um it means trying to accomplish things
that I've dreamed about but was never in
a position to try to accomplish
um or succeed at and and that's what I'm
trying to do now there's a Shark Tank
Company from last season called mush
right cool stuff it's like this um
oatmeal that they packaged it's fresh
dried oatmeal that they packaged with a
little spoon and you it has to be
refrigerated but you just grab it and go
and the the response was great from the
show and now like I just saw their
numbers they went from 50 000 in sales
to a hundred thousand to 125 000 in
three straight months it's not scale but
they're growing right and they all of a
sudden like okay we gotta go raise money
and we got to do yada yada right
scale is hard not just because of the
economic cost but also because of the
people cost and the mind share cost it's
hard when you're dealing with a major
comp and in particular if you're dealing
with a big company like a Walmart or
Costco or whatever because you only get
one shot of those guys and so like I
told mush with Whole Foods
they're interested I'm like you're not
ready
you're not ready you have got to you've
got to crawl before you ball you know
and it
and and and so
I told him it's going to be painful not
to go after that big customer
but think about what happens if you go
after it and a it's going to take
Capital you don't have and you're going
to borrow it or B it doesn't work out
and they return it all then all of a
sudden you're out of business and so
you're you're right that you need
Capital to scale but you also need
the confidence that you can scale and
that you can keep your customers happy
and so I always tell people get to the
point where you have you you've taken
care of the customers that you can take
care of once you can demonstrate that
then you can get smart money and you're
talking from a position of power and
then you can go to the Walmarts of the
world the Costcos and you may not even
have to raise money they may even
provide po leverage or po support or
connect you with a bank that does and so
I guess I guess what I'm saying is
don't get too far ahead of yourself
because sometimes sales can be a lot
more expensive than you think they are
and you've got to be careful I've seen
several my Shark Tank companies try to
get too big too fast and then almost put
them out of business you've never been
shy to speak up in issues that are
important to you and one of those themes
I've found has been around fairness and
whether that's you know calling out
referees for not calling games
consistently or you know calling out a
shark tank contestant because you think
that they're scamming their customers
how do you decide what you're going to
speak up on or do you hold inside you
know it's changed over the years
um because I have kids
because social media you know Twitter in
particular is so much different
um and has changed kind of the Rules of
Engagement
um it's changed because of what I went
through with the Mavericks last year I
missed a sexual harassment problem that
we had because I wasn't I took my eye
off the ball
um and so you know I try to be
self-aware and try to put myself in the
shoes of the person or people or
organization I'm talking about whether
it
adds value
um I try to put myself in the position
my own position you know how's it going
to be perceived and you know
is it worth it you know will it create
more good than challenges and and so
you've got to pick your spots do you own
any FUBU shirts no
why not
come away
I used to
you once said you try to read about
three hours every day that's a lot of
books
wouldn't you say yes
I've written five books have you read
any of them no
I promoted them but why not
next
what about Laurie grenier's book
invented sell it Bank it did you read
that she wrote a book
well
right
did you ever read the 50 Shades of Gray
series no but fun fact there's a picture
of me in the first movie really for real
what are you looking for when you get
pitched like top to I mean you get
pitched on television your real life you
clearly like I get to protest in the
restaurants in the restaurant bathrooms
yeah
um I look for something that makes me
think why didn't I think of that you
know or it makes me think oh my goodness
that's a good idea and then the
follow-up questions are you know is it
differentiated enough can they protect
it
um what's the unique element and then
the secondary parts of that or not even
secondary the the other part of it is
you know how good an entrepreneur is and
can I help them and so once you get once
I get past those initial hurdles whether
it's Shark Tank or just you know people
emailing me literally I've invested well
over 100 million dollars and the company
is for people I've never met to this day
interesting my dad did upholstery on
cars my mom um assault did whatever odd
jobs
um but my dad was always like if you
want something you have to earn it and
to his credit he never said no you can't
do that so whether it was selling
garbage bags baseball cards stamps
whatever it was he never held me back
and so I think that was as important as
anything and you know sometimes being
young and trying things you're so naive
and you don't know any better all you do
is learn and if you fail it doesn't
matter and so whether I 9 10 12 16 21
the failures were irrelevant and you
know whether you're you know 9 12 16 21
22 24 you know I'm sleeping on the couch
you know I have a car with a hole in the
floorboard you know I'm I'm living like
a bum and like a student and so what did
I have to lose and so I think that
influenced me as much as anything so you
know my dad was like go for it you know
don't why not what have you got to lose
you know you have to sleep on a
different couch what industry you think
still requires a lot of innovation all
of them
seriously I mean look
one of my dad's favorite sayings was you
don't live in the world you were born
into everything changes all the time and
you know what's better than change
creating change and so whenever I see
something that's done the way it's
always been done you know like when I
got to the NBA you know my whole goal is
just F things up right because data
everything was done the exact same way
they thought they were in the business
of basketball
for 50 years they thought they were in
the basketball business no when you go
to a basketball game you don't remember
the jump shots the dunks you remember
who you were with the fun you had it's
one of the few Industries where that
ball is in the air at the end of a game
everybody holds their breath and you're
if it goes in you're hugging people
you've never seen before you you know so
you can take any industry and look at
the way things have been done and try to
come up and innovate and you know and
like I said with just the nature of
capitalism right now all the changes
that are required
every industry needs change and there's
a unique opportunity that I don't think
any generation's ever seen I think
people will always stop and say well I
want to start a business what should I
do and if you don't know you're not
ready right you know you've got to have
something that you're good at and if
you're gonna be if you're gonna do it
you got to be the best at it because
I'll tell them look if I come in and
compete with you I'm going to kick your
ass are you ready to compete with me
right and you've got to work like
there's someone working 24 hours a day
to take it away from you being treating
people equally is not is not the same
is not recognizing who they truly are
and taking advantage of their skills you
know and I've learned that through sin
I've learned that through all this and
you know like sit in I talk will be a
much better organization I'll be a
better exec I'll be a better investor
I'll be a better
um shark
um because I recognize that you know
treating people equally is not the same
as treating them recognizing their
skills and their differences and for
this for this audience it's it's
critically important
you know and I think there's an
opportunity now and I know hopefully you
know people like me will recognize that
the old white guys now nearly old white
guys that are in positions of power that
there are things that you can do that I
can't do that I that there are things
you see that I don't see
there are opportunities that you can
create
that I can't create
you know we were trying to sell to the
black community Through the Mavs
with multiple white men
we were trying to sell to moms with
multiple white men
it's not that they're not capable it's
not that they're not skilled
it's just everybody brings something
different to the table and as an
entrepreneur you have to recognize what
the differences are that you bring to
the table and you have to be brutally
honest with yourself right you can't lie
to yourself like we all lie to ourselves
as entrepreneurs but those differences
can be part of your unique skill set
like I talked about earlier and now I'm
finally starting to recognize those
things and you know the one thing I know
it's going to make me a load more money
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Elon Musk check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you know I suppose it
was the
and a Plato or someone who said
[Music]
um or maybe attributed to our Socrates
if I if I know anything it's that I know
nothing